Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking. Question,
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought
to you by legal zoom,
which has been a longtime sponsor because
I've seen it helps so many different
businesses.
Hundreds and thousands of businesses of
yours is listeners and even including
some guests on this
show such as wordpress,
lead developer and automatic
founder Matt Mullenweg.
Legal Zoom is a reliable resource that
more than 1 million people have used to
successfully launch and run businesses.
Legal Zoom has been helping people
take care of their dreams and legal
responsibilities. Got To protect those
dreams. Folks for more than 16 years.
They're not a law firm,
but they have the resources
to keep you on the right path,
including advice from their network
of independent attorneys all at your
fingertips,
whether you want to take your business
to the next level or take control of your
family's future with an estate plan,
for instance.
That's actually one of the places
I started with legal zooms,
looking at wills and so on,
related to estate planning. Legal.
Zoom has options so you can take
care of the things that matter most.
Go to legal zoom.com and get
special savings when you enter Tim.
That's capital t I m in
the Promo box at checkout.
Special savings. What does
that mean? I'm not sure.
Mystery savings could be 100% could be
1% could be 10% could be 27 and a half
percent I dunno,
so go to legalzoom.com and get special
savings when you enter a Tim in the pro
box at checkout. That's
legalzoom.com and use Promo Code Tim.
This episode is brought to
you by wordpress.com I go
to platform for blogging
and creating websites.
wordpress.com which I've used for ages
now is the online home for this podcast,
tim.blog/podcast, my blog and
all of my standalone book sites.
So whether you're looking to create a
personal blog, a business site, or both,
creating your website on wordpress.com
helps others to find you,
remember you and connect with you.
Wordpress is designed for nontechnical
businesses and bloggers. That's me.
I am not getting nitty gritty in the code.
You do not need experience
setting up a website.
They take care of the technical side
so it's easy to get your site up and
running.
Their customer support team is available
to help 24 hours a day and not just
Monday through Friday, but also weekends
and if you look at the bigger picture,
28% of all websites run on wordpress,
which is mind blowing when you consider
it in plans. Start at just $4 per month.
Listeners of this podcast can receive
15% off any new plan purchase.
It's a good wordpress.com forward slash
Tim to create your website and find the
plan that's right for you.
That's wordpress.com forward Tim
for 15% off a brand new website.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
This episode is going to be a bit of an
anomaly and experiment and instead of my
usual long form interviews
where I deconstruct world
class performers to tease
out the habits, routines,
favorite books and so on.
I will share some details from my own
life and decision making and so on,
based on questions that have been up voted
by subscribers to five bullet Friday.
What is five bullet?
Friday?
Five bullet Friday is a free newsletter
that I send out every Friday that
includes the five coolest things I've
found or explored that week can include
what I'm reading, books, articles,
gadgets, uh, tech work arounds,
any type of experiments that I'm doing,
favorite purchases, et Cetera, et Cetera,
et cetera. And this newsletter has
proven to be very, very popular.
More than a million people subscribe has
more than a 60% open rate for those of
you in the email world, you know,
that is absolutely astonishing. Uh,
so people do look forward to this.
It's free.
It will always be phrased
if you want to check it out.
And they're also exclusive
meetups, opportunities to
ask me questions and so on.
Check it out at Tim Dot.
Blog forward slash Friday tim.blog
forward slash Friday and it's super short.
Five bullet point email with
lots of fun stuff every Friday,
something to help you get a little
morsel to chew on for your weekend,
so let's just jump right into
question number one. Hi Tim.
What are the top five health markers
to check and watch regularly?
This is a very tough question to
answer because so much of it would be
predicated on your personal situation,
biochemistry,
family history and so on. I'm not
going to totally dodge, but I will say,
and I'm paraphrasing here,
the words of much wiser doctors
that I work with. However,
above the age of 40 or so,
I want to say with a 70% or
greater likelihood you are
going to be killed or you
are going to die from one of
four things. Cancer, stroke,
heart attack or neurodegenerative
disease or complications thereof.
Looking at family history,
you can pretty quickly figure out which
are the primary candidates. In my case,
it's hard attack and neurodegenerative
disease like Alzheimer's and someone.
Therefore,
many of the things I do,
both track end preemptively
or preventatively treat
are going to be related to
heart attack, cardiovascular disease
or neurodegenerative disease.
All right, so that would dictate
say the use of Curcumin, like uh,
I think it's called a thera cumin,
something like that for instance,
or on the heart attack side
looking at other things.
But I want to refer everyone
to tim.blog forward slash A.
Tia, a t T. I a.
This will take you to episodes featuring
Dr Peter Attia who is one of the best
mds I know and I know a lot of mds.
He works with many,
many name brand folks as a concierge
doctor you would recognize has very
credible, uh, background. He is
exceptionally evidence-based,
also former ultra endurance athletes
swimming 25 plus mile swimming races and
things of that type.
So he understands and appreciates the
implications and also trade offs of say,
longevity versus performance,
which are very often at odds.
Does that mean you want 100% of one
and none of the other probably not.
So how do you navigate that
blend in any case specifically,
if you go to Tim dot.
Blog forward slash Tiaa look at episode
65 because he answers this question in
great detail and I may be
getting some of this wrong,
but I'm looking at the show notes and
here's what I see listed under medical
terminology, a apo e genotype. All right,
this can be indicative of your
predisposition to things like Alzheimer's,
Ldl particle number.
Alright,
particle number is a critical
piece of this Lp. Little a.
The next we have OGT that stands
for oral glucose tolerance test.
Then you have IGF one insulin
like growth factor one,
uh, does mohs drawl and few
other things are listed here. Uh,
and uh, very frequently if
you're talking with say Peter,
at least the way that he and I often do
things using either intermittent fasting
or extended periods of fasting,
say three contiguous days per month,
and then longer periods a few
times per year as a purge fast.
As discussed in my episode with Dr Dominic
D'agostino who was introduced to me
by Peter. Uh, this can be used as a, uh,
a plausible preventative
measure to counter cancer,
which is not one of my most likely
candidates to kill me personally,
although it certainly
is for a lot of folks.
And going between phases of say,
hypertrophy,
meaning muscle building and
performance optimization, uh,
alternating that with
periods of Autophagy, uh,
which you can help trigger this type of
cellular self cleaning through things
like fasting among others. Uh, exercise
certainly plays a role. All right,
so long story short, I defer to Peter.
Tia, go to Tim dot. Blog forts hush. Tia,
check out episode 65 specifically.
And this question is answered as his
first question from y'all. All right,
next I'm going to answer how do
you manage all of your contacts,
you know, so many people and
how they are all interrelated.
Do you have a specific system
or software to help you?
And I'm going to answer this with
a non answer, which is no, uh,
because I don't want to make it
seem like I have all the answers.
And that I'm selectively picking those I
have great answers to which will create
that illusion. So no, I do not have
software for this. I wish I did,
but simultaneously I am
nervous.
I suppose creeped out would be another
way to put it by the amount of data,
Google,
Facebook and so on.
Have Apple included and what they're
able to correlate without any input from
me.
For instance,
auto correcting names I've been texting
with or that I have off of what I
perceive to be the apple
platform and my phone. Uh,
or for instance a Facebook in some way,
a correlating based on
the app use on the phone.
People I've just added to contacts or
been texting with or names I've mentioned
with their suggested people
you should know on Facebook.
All of these things creep me out.
So I don't think I put in enough data,
uh,
or detail into my contacts to make
this a easily solvable by software.
Because even if you were to pull by
area code, say I'm traveling to Texas,
so I want to know who has a five one,
two area code,
let's just say so that I can ask certain
people out to lunch or dinner. Well,
people's physical addresses change
more often then their phone numbers.
Uh, so that is not an accurate
indicator. So the short answer is no.
What I try to do with my contacts,
because rightly,
I mean you have a,
I suppose inferred by the question that
I know thousands and meet thousands of
new people every single year.
I try to simply know one or two people
who are very strong in each given field
and through those people I can get to
anyone I might need. In other words,
I'm focusing on just in time
introductions and contacts,
not just in case contacts.
And this is a corollary to something that
Kathy Sierra taught me long time ago,
which was to focus on just in
time information. In other words,
and knowing how to find the information
you need when you need it as opposed to
just in case information.
Good example of that would
be reading business books.
Say on how to sell your company when
you're running a startup in the early
stages because you are going
to take notes properly,
forget everything and then have to reread
that book at a later point in time if
you ever pick it up again.
And that is a sunk cost.
So just in time information instead of
just in case information and just in time
contacts,
Visa v one or two highly competent
people in each field versus collecting
hundreds and thousands of business
cards and figuring out what to do with,
which is a more reactive way
to go about it. Next question,
have you or your guests any strategies
to prevent or minimize binge eating
during periods of stress?
Yes,
and the last two weeks have
been very stressful for me.
I've had many crises pop up at the same
time and it has been very challenging
and I will tell you that the first rule
is to eliminate from the home anything
that you would binge eat.
And this really underscores my belief
that your systems Trump willpower,
you should rely on proper
systems and restrictions,
environmentally speaking versus this
thing that we like to think of as
discipline or willpower, which is
very fallible. And case in point,
uh,
I have come home from late dinners or say
two glasses of wine during this period
of high stress, landed
home, gone into the Pantry,
deliberately looking for things
to snack on, any bit of chocolate,
any bag of potato chips,
anything that might remotely
qualify as a chief food.
And instead I find mustard MCT oil,
athletic greens,
protein powder,
canned beans,
not interesting whatsoever
as late night cheat foods.
And therefore I don't end up bingeing
when I violate that. For instance,
about six days ago,
I was visiting a consumer packaged good
company and they gave me three amazing
bags of,
I'll say potato chips,
but they're really tortilla chips made
from different types of root vegetables
and so on. Delicious. And came
back one night and what did I do?
I had these three bags that are never
in my pantry and I promptly eight all
three bags,
2100 calories of these tortilla chips,
and they were delicious. Did I regret
that? Yes. Did I feel guilty? Yes.
Did I think less of myself for having done
it? Yes. So keep it out of your house.
If you have anything that is chief food
in your house, removed from your house,
that is system overwhelmed.
Power number one.
Number two is get your breakfast right.
So if you consume,
for instance,
what I would consider perhaps a,
an ideal breakfast for many people,
30 grams of protein within 30 minutes
of waking up, which means you wake up,
you have breakfast,
and that could be say three eggs,
three whole eggs is what Gretchen
Ruben does as well. By the way,
for those of you who heard her on
the podcast sometime ago, three eggs,
some spinach could be microwave.
It doesn't make a difference to me,
but let's just say a
little bit of spinach.
So you have that fiber and then you
also have some type of black beans or
lentils or pinto beans.
Some type of beans and save three eggs,
uh, lentils or beans,
and then some spinach,
the composition of that meal,
the Macros, so to speak,
the protein load plus the fiber content
will help to stave off any type of a
binge inclination for the rest of the day.
And there's a very,
very good chance if you just fix
that meal. If you just dial in,
that is your new default
breakfast that you will consume,
say 15 to 30% fewer calories
for the rest of the day.
This is very,
very common and is also why
if you have a hundred pounds,
150 pounds,
200 pounds to lose,
and many people have done this on the
slow carb diet and you can search how to
lose a hundred pounds slow carb diet for
free case studies and instructions on
how to do this with photographs.
Uh,
I will first ask that they do nothing
other than change their breakfast.
Why is a lead domino that then has many
downstream effects that you could treat
as independent decisions otherwise,
but that would lead to decision fatigue.
So why not look at all these decisions
and ask yourself which of these if made
or done correctly would make the
others automatic irrelevant or easier.
And the answer is fixing breakfast
and there are other guidelines,
but really those are two of the
primaries. All right, next question.
What's next for you now that
your book is launched? Uh,
the book that is referred to in
this question is tribe of mentors.
We'll try for mentors and thanks to
all of you. Thank you very, very much.
Ended up number one,
New York Times Number One Wall
Street Journal and it is in orbit.
So it is reached escape velocity and
it is always my job just to get the
flywheel spinning. And if the book is any
good, it sticks. If not, then it doesn't.
But this one appears to have stuck and
at this point I view my job as saying no
to a thousand things and
creating space to listen.
This is along the lines of what Tim
O'reilly has shared on this podcast and if
you haven't heard that episode of
highly recommend you check it out.
If you're asking yourself, Tim, who
all the more reason to go check it out,
but creating space to listen,
to really just exist and develop
a higher level of perception.
So I am focused on all manner
of things to assist that, uh,
such as testing a Beta version of the
waking up APP by my friend Sam Harris,
who's also been on this pod before,
who manages to somehow speak in fully
formed pros paragraphs or blocking out
time. Whether that is, for instance,
this weekend when I will be going to an
airbnb way out in the country here in
Texas with no Wifi,
no reception whatsoever or
say more extended trips of
two to three weeks with my
family, which I do twice a year
after reading the tail end,
an essay by Tim urban on wait,
but why?
Which put the remaining number of hours
as a percentage of the total that I'll
spend with my family before they die,
my parents specifically into perspective
or a blocking out an entire month to
hopefully go off the grid without
using any social media or electronics,
which I'm in the process of planning now.
Why would I want to do this?
I mentioned this in brief earlier,
but developing a higher sensitivity and
ability to perceive this can be helpful.
Whether you are doing some explicit type
of work such as cal Newport's deep work
say which requires extended
periods of uninterrupted time,
blocks of time,
or if you are simply trying to be more
aware and develop an awareness of how you
feel,
how you think,
how you react in perhaps a
vipassana meditation respect,
uh,
so that your ability to parse
life and be less reactive is uh,
developed over time,
which is something certainly I'm
paying a lot of attention to right now.
Especially given the number of crises
that have hit in the last a week or two,
which has proven to me the value of
this type of training and deliberately
creating space to listen.
Allah,
Tim O'reilly and that is o Apostrophe,
r.
E. I. L. L. Y. For those of you who
wants to check it out. All right.
Next question is about EDC.
Every day carry, what do you keep
on your person as part of your EDC?
How do you carry it? How does it change
during travel or other activities slash?
Events? Bonus points if you
do a pocket dumb. All right.
Short answer is I have a very
unimpressive EDC when you consider my pant
pockets. I don't like keeping things
in my pant pocket so I don't have much.
I do use a Patagonia lightweight
fleece vest oftentimes as my walking,
uh,
portable bag that I wear on myself.
But the backpack is,
is really the standard form and it travels
with the almost everywhere that I go.
And I have a number of different pack
backs including one made by dots with Sada
da t s u s a r a made out of hemp,
which was or is I should say a company
created by a reader after going through
the four hour work week, which is fun. Uh,
and in that backpack there are
a number of things that, uh,
I travel with at all times,
including the rubs ball.
Are you busy ball? Looks like a golf
ball with a little prongs on it.
And that was introduced
to me by Amelia Boone,
four time world champion in obstacle
course racing for you say before flights,
after flights, uh, during
any period of travel.
And it alleviates tightness and pain,
not just in the feet but all the way up
through the legs, the posterior chain,
the hips, it unlocks more than you would
expect. So that always travels with me.
A headlamp. I always have a headlamp
in a side pocket very often.
Black diamond sprayable
zinc for bolstering the
immune system and Melatonin,
typically three milligram tablets.
Uh,
and everyone from art Devani to Dominic
D'agostino are fans of Melatonin and use
of different points.
Voodoo floss for self care,
different types of joint issues
created by Kelly Starr at,
you can Google that for more
of a journal of some type.
Very frequently the five minute
journal or morning pages,
but the morning pages paperback
is exceptionally heavy.
So I often ditch that
earplugs most frequently.
Max Silicone Potty earplugs.
So you can sleep on,
say your side without having
foam poke into your inner ear.
And then and I'm ask of some type and
the sleep master ims is one I use very
frequently.
It also covers the ears and the outside
as opposed to digging in with an elastic
strap.
The only caveat is that it can be very
warm so I also collect eye masks from
various flights and so on. If you were
to look at what I carried some time ago,
for instance when I was reading the four
hour chef and got really into prepper
Ville and all of that, I would
have had a multi tool in my wallet.
It would look like a metal business
card with little nooks and crannies for
Phillip's head screwdriver,
say saw edge et cetera.
That was recently confiscated by
the Tsa. Surprise, surprise. Uh,
I would also have potentially a sure fire,
a flashlight,
tactical flashlight in my bag and
then I would have a para cord,
wrist band or bracelet of some type.
If you're wondering what
you could use para cord for,
the answer is almost
anything including bow drill,
which is a bit of an edge case
for all practical purposes,
but you can look up bow drill.
If you want to see how to make fire using
something like para cord that is woven
into a bracelet.
And you could also look up Tim Ferriss
experiment Los Vegas escape to see some
of the training I did with
onpoint tactical and Kevin
Reeve where we looked at
getting out of zip ties,
getting out of handcuffs and
all sorts of other craziness.
So you can check that out at your leisure.
But these days I don't have
a whole hell of a lot, uh,
in terms of EDC,
suppose now that I live in Texas,
I could go get my concealed carry and
that would add a whole new layer to
paranoia, danger and a potential
offense. So there you have it.
Such defense, right? Next up,
we have most valuable skills for financial
freedom and being better with money.
Question Mark.
This is a super dicey question.
So I'm going to add a
very important preamble,
which is I am not a
professional investment advisor,
nor do I play one on the Internet. So this
is for informational purposes only. Uh,
a lot of people take
everything I say literally,
and that is dangerous.
So don't do that.
Use Your own brain and much like the
question of what are the top five health
markers to check and watch regularly.
Most valuable skills for financial freedom
and being better with money is highly
personalized. But what I would
say is that if you are in debt,
if you have a substantial amount of debt,
uh,
I have found for instance,
or I've,
I've certainly heard from hundreds of
listeners and readers that Dave Ramsey is
very helpful. Uh, some people
are very big fans of Rich Dad,
poor dad by Kiyosaki and the quadrants.
Pr In particular in that book,
uh, is something that many have
found useful. Uh, Rameet Seti,
good friend of mine, a r a, M. I t. S.
E t h I is a very adept and I think
very smart in this particular arena.
And if you want to look up
automated finance system,
Rameet Ra, MIT and then Tim Ferris, uh,
he has a guest blog post on my blog.
A that is very,
very popular, has been very popular over
the years and is worth taking a look at.
So I,
I do think that if you are in debt,
those three places are
good places to start.
Beyond that, I can really only
speak from personal experience,
but financial freedom can entail a lot
and can mean many things to different
people.
That could mean lack of debt.
It could mean being able to do whatever
you want, in which case, uh, the,
the sky's the limit.
Perhaps you need tens of millions
or hundreds of millions of dollars.
If you want to buy that jet,
it could mean financial freedom that
you are free from financial worry.
It no longer occupies 20% of your ram at
all times and being better with money.
All right?
I would divide being better with
money into two different categories.
And keeping in mind that for me,
a good investment is one that
increases your quality of life.
Why otherwise would you invest?
So if you say are invested in crypto
and the percentage gains are very
attractive,
but you're a complete crackhead
compulsively checking the charts every 15
minutes,
is that a good investment?
Well that's a question
for you to sit with,
but if it progressively worsens your
quality of life or consistently creates
more anxiety than you had beforehand,
is the marginal utility of the dollars
you are gaining as reflected in that
percentage enough to offset that with
some type of lump sum payment of happiness
or improved quality of life at the end?
Maybe not,
but this is something worth considering
coming back to what I was saying though,
I tend to think of
money as a getting rich,
staying rich.
So there are different tools in the
toolkit for getting rich different tools
then in the staying rich category.
And uh,
I would say if you're looking
at beating the market, so Alpha,
I th I don't do that in a
hands off styles of investing.
Uh, I, I have that very much
on one side of my barbell.
So I personally,
uh,
partially by choice and partially
by fate have ended up with a very,
a barbell looking asset distribution.
And if you were to look at what I have,
you're going to have highly volatile
what most people would consider highly
risky class of investments,
namely startups and cryptocurrency.
That's going to be more
than 50% of my total assets.
Uh,
and then you have real estate and cash
or cash equivalence and that's pretty
much it.
So on opposite ends of the spectrum,
and we could debate whether
or not real estate is risky,
we could debate the benefits of cash if
you also have to contend with inflation.
Well,
let's just keep it simple for the sake
of this discussion and say that you have
a highly volatile,
what most people would consider high risk,
high reward categories like privately
held startups and cryptocurrency on one
end of the Barbell,
which is where I create my alpha.
And then you have real estate cash,
cash like equivalents and
things like for instance,
a Muni bonds and so on where you
would then preserve that alpha.
Okay, so you create Alpha, take it
off the table and then preserve Alpha.
Now forget about the question
of converting crypto into
Fiat or keeping it in
crypto. Let's just keep it simple. Uh,
so that is currently what my
asset allocation would look like.
That is very,
very likely to change over time and I
should address a couple of questions that
likely come to mind.
One would be why on earth do you have
more than 50% of your net worth and
startups and crypto and it is not because
I had a hundred units of assets and
decided to put 50 plus percent of
those units into crypto and startups.
That would be complete insanity.
I think for almost anyone.
It's because I started off with
a very reasonable allocation.
Some of you might remember that
many years ago, 2008 or so,
I created for myself a real world MBA
rather than going to a Stanford GSB or one
of these graduate school
programs and business,
I decided to take the same amount of
money over two years. At that point,
it was $60,000 a year for two years.
And invest that into the Tim Ferriss
Fund in quotation marks to try my hand at
startup investing in the very beginning,
piggybacking and co-investing with
people who knew what they were doing.
And I assumed the network
built the skills, developed,
the knowledge acquired over that two
year period of time would benefit me more
than the $120,000,
which I assumed I would lose.
Or the assumption was much like
tuition that would be a sunk cost.
And that then set me on this accidental
career of being an early stage tech
angel investor and advisor.
And that tiny sliver of my
total pie chart at that time,
due to a lucky slash good investments
and companies selection has swollen to a
gigantic percentage of the total pie
chart with companies like Uber, Facebook,
Twitter, Alibaba, and so on. Uh,
crypto very similarly, uh, has,
has not,
uh,
necessarily risen as it would have had
I gone in early with something like a
theory, them, uh,
but has nonetheless doubled and so
on over time, more than doubled.
So compete, if you look at my cost
basis, it was a very rational,
well semi rational decision at the t at
the time to allocate what I allocated.
But due to growth, uh,
they now represent a very,
very large percentage of my total holdings
and the crypto can be freely traded,
the startups are locked up.
All right?
So I am unable to decrease my
positions and balance those,
uh, for the most part. And that is why
my portfolio, it looks the way it does.
I would not recommend my,
uh,
asset allocation to really anyone.
Um,
now this comes back to,
uh,
the question of financial freedom,
getting better with money.
If we're looking at the,
the getting rich part,
the building wealth for a
less crass way to put it,
a building wealth preserving off
sounds a lot fancier, much more, uh,
Rockefeller. Then nouveau riche. So
let's stick with that. All right.
Building wealth, preserving
wealth. The way that I have a,
if we're assuming there's some aspect of
skill involved and that I'm not just a
lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky,
which could be the case, right?
If you have a thousand orangutans
flip coins long enough,
as Warren Buffett would say, Oh,
actually, Warren buffet wouldn't say this.
The efficient market market
theorists folks would say this,
you have a thousand
monkeys flipping coins.
Eventually you're going to find one
or two monkeys who flip, you know,
50 heads in a row and then end up writing
books about how to flip coins and so
on. So maybe I'm that monkey. But, uh, if
we assume there's some element of skill,
the way that I've thought
about it is number one,
a capping downside first versus evaluating
upside and looking at the minimal
downside. And this is borrowed
from a lot of folks, including, uh,
some famous names you might recognize.
Warren Buffett, for instance,
a WHO's a would be considered,
I think by most a value investor or the
Charlie Munger has certainly informed
their, their leader investment styles. Uh,
Paul Tudor Jones of hedge fund fame.
And this is actually a quote that I
took from Tony Robbins book unshakeable,
uh, which is, which is very good or money
master the game also very, very good.
Is this truly the hard trade? And this
is from Paul Tudor Jones. Paraphrasing,
is this truly the hard
trade question mark?
Meaning something others
can't easily replicate?
Does this really have
asymmetric risk reward?
Is it a five to one or three to one?
That means for every dollar he is risking,
is there the potential or
expectation of a three or $5 Roi?
What's the entry point? What are your
stops? Right? These are all really,
really good questions.
And the downside risk happening,
the downside risk is also something that,
for instance, Richard Branson does and
when he started a Virgin Atlantic, uh,
negotiating a lease with Boeing so that
he could return the plane or planes if
it didn't work out.
So even these people who are
viewed as in veteran risk takers,
people to throw caution to the wind are
in fact determining how to limit their
downside right up front and then
looking for asymmetric risks.
So in the startup world,
uh, that check the box,
you can put in 25 k Max,
you know,
your maximum that you can lose because
you're not using leverage or anything
else.
25 k is the maximum you can lose.
And yet there is the potential if you,
uh,
focus on an unfair advantage
and we'll come back to that,
that you could have a hundred,
2000 x return and the startup world,
much like a publishing book,
publishing music and these are
hits driven businesses, uh,
a you are betting on companies or books
or musicians were albums that you hope
will return the fund.
They will return all of the other losses
that you will incur a with your other
bets. And uh, I do very well
with those types of decisions.
They are binary,
they're not day trading.
They're certainly not a considering
buying or selling on a regular basis,
uh, at which point you become
very susceptible to mister market.
If you want to look up
Warren Buffet, Mr Market, uh,
that is who I am in public markets.
So I do not play much with public
ally traded equities for instance,
even though that might be part
of my portfolio later. Uh,
instead I like to do a
ton of research upfront,
make a Binary Decision Min,
min out, and then I'm stuck.
And that being stuck
is actually a benefit.
It is a constraint that works for me
in this case because I can't make sell
decisions at the wrong time.
It is out of my hands. Uh,
that does not suit everyone's
intestinal fortitude.
It just happens to suit
my weird psychology. Uh,
the unfair advantage I mentioned I would
come back to is really only playing
with a stacked deck.
Uh,
so I do not make investments in startups
where I cannot materially impact
directly the value of that company or
from the selection standpoint when I have
a, unless I have a significant
informational advantage.
And when I lived in silicon valley,
was there for 17 years,
I lived in the middle of the switchbox
and I made every effort to ensure that I
was in the hub of information flow.
So I knew about things,
uh, weeks, months in some
cases, years in advance.
And that enabled me to
make better decisions as to
where it should allocate the
Tim first fund and the first two years
certainly, which worked out very,
very well and had some great teachers who
have all talked about their approaches
for investing on this podcast.
Uh, naval Ravikant. Incredible.
So you can go to tim.blog forward slash
and if all you can go to tim.blog,
uh, forward slash. Let's see. Actually
it might not be a forward slash,
but if you look up Mike maples and a p, l,
e s, he's another one who has been very,
very consistently good and so
on and so forth. All right,
so this is a long answer, but
for financial freedom, uh,
first understanding how to get
out of debt or how to manage debt,
uh, I use very, very
little debt in my life.
Some people are very
comfortable with that. I am not.
And being better with money is in
part not being afraid of money.
And also,
uh,
learning how to take small steps and
moderate actions with limited downside
rather than being paralyzed by any
insecurities or fears you might have about
money.
So book that I think holistically can
help with that is how to stop worrying and
start living by Dale Carnegie has
nothing directly to do with money,
but it does have everything to do with
how you might interact with money.
Uh,
the last thing I would say is coming
back again to financial freedom is to
correct a misconception about the
spectrum between full time employed an
entrepreneur.
Uh,
there is the erroneous belief
of the false dichotomy that,
that these things exist completely
separately. In other words that you,
you're either a nine to fiver or work
for someone else or you quit that job and
chase your dreams and your
full time entrepreneur. Uh,
I don't recommend in most cases that
you make that black and white leap.
In fact,
it makes much more sense to moonlight
to side Gig on the say the weekends or
Saturdays for a period of time so that
you can both assess and evaluate your
ideas for a company.
Uh,
but also assess and evaluate your own
abilities as an entrepreneur to for
instance, structure time that
is otherwise unstructured,
to set your own rules and policies instead
of having them set by someone else or
some type of company environment.
Uh,
and not everyone is suited
to the uncertainty that
you face as an entrepreneur
on an ongoing basis. And there's
nothing wrong with that. Uh, it's,
it comes down to accurately assessing
your strengths and weaknesses, uh,
which certainly applies to investment.
And guess what? It's all investment,
investment of money, time,
energy, attention. These are
all investment decisions.
All right. I covered the asset allocation
and why you should never copy me.
And, uh, let's go to the
next. All right. Hi Tim.
I know this is a bit out of your
normal focus, but I'm curious,
do you have a philosophy about
having or not having children up?
This is one of the undecided
categories. Uh, so hopefully my,
my somewhat non-answer will be reassuring
to people who are in a similar place.
But, uh, I'm conflicted about this, uh,
because on on one hand, if we're
talking about investing and betting,
let's just say if I look at the divorce
rates in the United States and the
damage that can be done, certainly based
on talking to my friends who are the,
the children of divorced
parents by divorce, uh,
I wouldn't bet on marriage
the institution, uh,
to support,
uh,
or rather to have a fantastic
outcome if I were betting on, uh,
on partnerships the way that
I would bet on startups,
I wouldn't bet on partnerships period a
longterm and whether they're within the
confines of marriage or
have some other arrangement.
Uh,
so there's a lot of hesitancy on
my part for all those reasons.
Uh, the, there are other ways to
look at this. Of course, very,
there are friends of mine who are either
divorced or are probably headed towards
divorce. And I would ask them, uh,
if the only way they could have
their kids was to get married,
knowing they would absolutely get a
divorce, would they still have their kids?
And the answer is invariably, yes.
Now, is this confirmation bias?
At this point,
probably it would be very hard for any
parent with a heart to say absolutely
not. I would unwind the
clock and not have my kids.
I have yet to meet anyone
who has said that. Uh,
and then there are folks, for
instance, Jersey Gregorich,
the Olympic weightlifting champion
who's 63 right now, I believe in,
I would consider one of my mentors.
He's in my ted talk,
if you're interested to learn more about
him. Uh, Tim. Dot. Blog forward slash ted.
But, uh, he has said to me privately, I
don't think he would mind me sharing this,
but he's like, ah, because I asked him how
I should think about kids. And he said,
well, you know, if you're a
guy you get past the age of x,
I think he was saying like 45 50
and you don't have kids. He's like,
that's just weird. He is
a very direct, he's like,
you just go crazy inside your own head if
you don't have kids by that point. And,
uh,
I think the simplicity that is actually
really profound and that the fact of the
matter is I may get to a point
where my biological imperative,
the Darwinian evolution that has led me
to this point being alive on this planet
in this particular period in time,
uh,
to want to have kids or feel
the need to have kids, uh,
despite any arguments to the contrary.
And,
uh,
at that point I might say fuck it
and pull the trigger and have kids.
Although I recognize that
it's not always that simple.
And a lot of men assume that the fertility
piece of the equation is problematic
if the woman has problems.
But I will tell you right now,
given the trending that I have seen and
morphology motility in a sperm among men
and decreases in testosterone and
everything else due to factors,
we can cover another time,
uh,
that it's never quite or very often not
as simple as people would like to think.
Uh, and that the fertility problems
experienced by couples are very much,
uh,
are very often attributable to the
men and not necessarily the woman.
All right?
Next you often ask your interviewees for
their advice for a younger person or a
younger version of themselves,
what advice have you distilled from your
guests or your own experience that we
would be appropriate for those over 40?
And I'll keep this super short,
uh,
this answer or I say this question and
the assorted answers from guests are most
represented in my last two books,
tools of titans and especially tribe of
mentors where you see many, many, many,
many different options.
And with rare exception,
the advice that would apply to those
over 40 is exactly the same advice that,
that these various guests would give to
younger people with the exception of,
uh, perhaps risking it all
in some capacity because you,
you don't have mortgages,
you don't have kids, right?
So apart from the hey kid,
you should try the crazy stuff
because you have no mortgage, no kids,
no real responsibilities. Aside from that
advice, which is really a small subset,
maybe 10 to 15% of the answers,
all of the rest of the advice applies.
Uh, the reason I ask, what would you,
what advice would you give your younger
self or what advice would you give a
high school senior or a college senior?
Is that the people I'm interviewing
feel qualified to give that advice.
Whereas if I said,
what advice would you give to every four
year old and they're 35 or they're 45
or maybe even 60,
they will be more reserved in,
in the prescription of advice
for those older groups than they,
than they will be with the younger groups.
And so it's,
it's really a tactical decision on my
part also just to get a more relaxed,
less edited answer from these
people. All right. Next question.
Do you think people who are
introverted should practice, develop,
learn to be more extroverted or just
embrace being introvert? You can do both.
I would consider myself an introvert,
a at least as defined by someone who is
recharged by being alone are with very,
very few people. And, uh,
I've never taken the Myers Briggs test,
but I'm constantly told I'm an
I n t j second most frequent,
uh,
what the precise term diagnosis would be.
INTP but,
uh,
certainly I would consider myself an
introvert who has trained himself to for
short periods of time,
be an extrovert a and get up on
stage and give speeches and so on.
But I avoid large groups
nearly all of the time.
And even if I go to a large dinner party,
I will frequently take five minute breaks
every half hour or so just to recharge
and gather my bearings.
So I take a lot of bathroom breaks when
I go to group events or conferences or
anything like that.
So you don't need to be more extroverted
at all. It depends a lot on your goals,
but they're certainly very introverted,
uh,
high performers with exceptional careers,
both inside of companies as
employees or entrepreneurs.
And then outside of companies are in
their own companies as entrepreneurs and
even CEOs,
you do not need to be a flamboyant PT
Barnum Steve Jobs type to be an effective
executive at all.
So it's,
it's really dependent on your objectives.
I will say that I agree
with Warren Buffet, uh,
that public speaking is one of the best
investments you can make some type of
training course.
I believe that he was part of toastmasters
or it may have just been a course he
took in public speaking.
But when you take the ability
to communicate messages
effectively to groups of
people and layer it on top
of almost anything else,
you automatically put yourself
into rarefied company. Uh,
so public speaking I do
think is a useful skill. Uh,
and in fact even a necessary skill,
uh,
depending on where your
decision tree takes you in life.
So that would be one addition.
Even if you are introverted,
I would suggest getting better at some
type and practicing public speaking.
All right. Next question. Uh,
how do you arrange the interior
of your home? Uh, example,
given layout items, displayed,
restored furnishings, et Cetera,
to optimize your mental
state and effectiveness. Is
this a consideration? Yes,
this is a major consideration
for me. And, uh,
I am not perfect by any
stretch of the imagination,
but I do spend a lot of time at home
and I would say just a few things are,
are particularly important to me.
I dislike clutter in any of my living
spaces like a living room. For instance,
I'm in my living room right now.
I have artwork up that
elicits very positive emotions
for me and I have books up
that elicit positive enabling
emotions or memories for me.
So for instance, I have up on the wall,
I have a photograph that Matt Mullenweg,
my buddy's CEO of Automattic,
uh,
one of the lead developers of wordpress
took when we were traveling in Vietnam.
And that is up on a shelf to remind me
of that particular trip where I was able
to say no and take time off the grid
without any side effects or negative
consequences that I can recall.
Then I have a book from Jocko Willink
that is the discipline equals freedom
field manual.
Uh,
because I'm a fan of Jocko and
whenever I'm being a complete wimp, uh,
with any decisions that
need to make ownership,
I need to take or a
discomfort I need to face,
then Jacos on the shelf yelling at me.
There I have the Ketogenic Bible,
a book called less is more just an
anthology of writing on minimalism.
I have the essential Rumi poetry,
a book called braiding sweetgrass,
the novel Musashi, uh,
two books on Musashi,
actually a Miyamoto Musashi who is
fought to be one of the greatest,
if not the greatest swordsman
in Japanese history. Uh,
a book called the book of laughter
and forgetting by Milan Kundera,
which I have a lot of positive association
with a Ray Daleo principles and then
go boards and other things.
A woodblock prints.
And I'm listing off a few things
here. Just see, you have an idea,
a photograph of a,
an Olympic weightlifter in a training
hall doing clean and jerk with several
hundred pounds.
The nameplate in effect,
it's a piece of fabric that was stitched
into the back of my Judah uniform when
I competed in judo as an exchange
student in Japan at age 15.
So I unstitched that from my judogi when
I was 15 and I've carried it with me
ever since with my name and my school
name underneath that and so on and so
forth. A lot of wildlife,
a lot of scenery.
So I have panoramic shots of waterfalls
and ponds in the Pacific northwest,
like Oregon. I've photograph of a gigantic
grizzly bear coming out of the water,
I think it's called majesty rising,
which is a photograph by Paul Nicklen,
a national geographic photographer.
He was just incredible.
And one of the few people I follow,
one of the few photographers
I follow on Instagram,
Cristina Mittermeier as well. Uh, it
would be, it would be high up, but yes,
I think a lot about what is placed
around my home and what type of emotional
states they prompt.
Uh,
so that is short answer to that.
All right,
next question.
Uh,
productivity for non type a people,
much of your advice.
And that of your guests seems to be aimed
at people who thrive with setting and
maintaining routines.
Do you have advice for those of us who
are ambitious but see routines is an
undesirable daily grind? Uh, yes,
I do have advice and it
is not avoid routines.
It is to reframe routines as something
enabling it is a positive constraint that
allows you to avoid decision fatigue
and allocate your brain power and the
creative competitive advantages to
the things that actually matter,
which is not choosing what to have for
breakfast in the morning or deciding
which coffee shop to go
to, etc. Uh, routines.
I think this is w h outdone from
getting the name correct. Uh,
should be seen as a in the
intelligent man be seen.
And that's of course people in general
seen in the intelligent man as a sign of
ambition.
Uh,
so instead of seeing routines
as an undesirable daily
grind to reframe routines,
rituals,
if you prefer that word as scaffolding
around which you can craft your best life
without that, every day is
a free for all. And it's,
it's effectively an unwritten script
that you have to write every single day
before you can even think about how to
perform the script best you have to write
it.
And that draws upon your very limited
resources in an incredible draining way,
in my experience.
So my answer is not to get rid of
routines and not to avoid routines,
but to reframe them as the scaffolding,
the reliable scaffolding around which
you can then build your best life every
day and utilize your unique strengths
in the least wasteful way possible.
All right. Uh, next question. And
I only have four or five left here.
All right. So the next question
is, how's life in Austin?
Have you designed or chosen a new house
according to any changes that you've
wanted to make in your lifestyle?
Uh, I'll answer the first piece. Uh,
Austin's great.
I've,
I'm living in Austin has made me fall
more in love with the city then simply
visiting.
And that was a concern.
I wasn't sure what it would be like
living here as an Austinite, uh,
but it's absolutely spectacular
and I'm exceptionally,
exceptionally bullish on Austin.
Uh,
so I've doubled and tripled and quadrupled
down on this town. A very, very,
very big fan. I'll keep it short. But if
you haven't visited at the very least,
live music capital of the u s
fantastic barbecue friendly people.
It's, it's a great town. So I encourage
everybody to check it out. Next questions.
Uh,
what questions should they ask themselves
to determine there were of happiness.
I've talked about where of happiness and
how I ended up at Austin for myself. Uh,
the easiest way to determine, and just
as context people think about the what,
what should I do? The who
should I spend time with, the Y,
etc. Of determining
their optimal happiness,
what job should I do and what type
of people should I spend time around?
And the wear is very important.
The geography,
the city or state place in which you
put yourself a determines a lot of these
other things.
My recommendation is to do an 80,
20 analysis of your last calendar year.
So I'm recording this in late February,
but it doesn't really matter.
Go back and look at your
calendar for the last year.
This should only take an afternoon.
Really.
You can do it on a Saturday for instance,
or a Sunday and go through and uh,
you,
you will fill in two columns.
The first column is the 20% of people
are activities that produced a peak
positive emotional states.
Most of the time,
my peak positive emotional states,
the 20% of say, people in activities
that produce 80% of the joy,
so to speak,
on the other side,
you're going to have the 20% of people
or activities that produced 80% of the
negative emotional states, the
irritation, the frustration,
the annoyance, uh, the anger,
etc. And you're going to make a list in
that column that's going to be or not to
do list. All right? Uh,
then you're gonna look at the positive
and you're going to look for a different
locations that have a high density
slash ease of encountering those things.
So for instance,
I noticed in my own calculus that
acroyoga correlated to a high degree of
happiness for me. If I practice
acro yoga a few times a week,
and if you want to see what the hell
that is, just look up acro yoga,
like acrobatic yoga, acro yoga,
Tim Ferris on, uh, the youtubes.
Uh, you could also go to
youtube.com forward slash
timferriss and you'll see some
video of this including me putting
a Jimmy Fallon up on my feet. And,
uh,
I then looked on Facebook at different
cities and the Acro Yoga community in
Austin, Texas is gigantic. It's
larger, at least based on Facebook.
Then the acro yoga community in
the bay area where it was created,
which blew my mind.
So that was then one of the positive
checkboxes when I was looking for density
slash ease of things based on a calendar
audit that have created a reliable
degree of happiness and improved quality
of life through doing that exercise.
So that's what I would do next up.
If for some reason or another you could
record only one more podcast who'd you
interview and why they can be dead or
alive. I would interview my parents, uh,
because I would want to have that record
really just for myself of having a long
form conversation with them and
capturing their story and their wisdom.
I don't think I would share that for
public consumption, but just for me,
which is actually a recommendation that
I received from a name that I mentioned
earlier in this podcast. Matt Mullenweg
one of the sweetest, smartest guys I know,
uh, who's also been on this podcast
talking about building companies, uh,
automatic. His company's worth more
than a billion dollars at this point,
I believe, and has a distributed
architecture of four or 500 employees.
It's really fascinating.
In any case,
he made that recommendation to me and
this is a good reminder to get on it.
So thanks for that Matt. And thanks for
this question to remind me. Next question.
What are the pros cons
of a silent retreat? Uh,
the pros would be similar to
some psychedelic experiences.
Not that I would recommend those in any
illegal context or in an unsupervised
fashion whatsoever.
But when you do a 10 day silent retreat,
which I made significantly harder
for myself by fasting during,
so I fasted for about seven days to prior
to ensure that I was to adapted five
during a for the first half of
my 10 day silent retreat. It,
that type of experience shows you the
breadth and depth of experience possible
through meditation. So you will see
the best you will see the worst.
You will be listless than you will be.
Uh,
you will be not fatigued.
You'll be restless. You'll want,
you'll be bouncing off the walls
with no real clear explanation. Uh,
you will have profound
moments of peace and uh,
and thoughtlessness or your ego seems
to dissolve and then you will have times
when, like me, right
before I broke my fast,
the only two thoughts in my head were
fried chicken, Calamari, fried chicken,
Calamari, fried chicken,
calamine for like three hours.
And then the next day it
was like ass porn as porn.
Just thinking about porn
basically for three hours,
which might sound reasonably
good. It was awful. Uh,
particularly when you're trying to focus
on your breathing or do something else
other than thinking about such things.
So it will show you the breadth and
depth of the experience possible through
meditation and that can then inform your
later practice. So when you have these,
perhaps rare or at least intermittent
experiences of profound peace and feeling
at ease with yourself and
everything in the world,
and perhaps even the disillusion of
the self in the sense that you feel
connected to all people,
all things that can be a
very tantalizing epiphany,
uh, beautiful, uh,
experience that then motivates
you to meditate later. Uh,
similar to the effect that
psychedelics had on Sam Harris Phd,
who I mentioned earlier,
uh, who then, uh, has,
has passed on. Psychedelics no
longer uses psychedelics, but, uh,
used that experience,
that promise, so to speak,
the light at the end of the tunnel.
Having the firsthand opportunity
to do that through psychedelics,
uh, to then drive his meditation
practice, which is now very,
very well developed and a lifeline for
him that is available at any given moment.
Right?
So those are few of the pros
of the seller treat cons.
All right. And not unlike a
powerful psychedelic experience. Uh,
I would say out of 100 people,
10 to 15% are going to have a as close
to a psychotic break as one can imagine
or an actual psychotic break.
And that is terrifying.
And I was in that 10 to 15% in the
silent retreat and I think I had a longer
conversation about this with uh,
Dan Harris on his podcast,
10% happier. And also on a,
an episode of this podcast,
which should be out by the time you
hear this or it's coming up very,
very shortly after this
episode with Jack Kornfield,
who was in fact the person who saved me
and allowed me to return to having my
feet on the ground well enough to leave
the silent retreat after that 10 day
silent retreat at spirit rock and Woodacre
California. So I would encourage you,
if you want more details on that,
oh,
you didn't expect to be in that 10 to 15%,
which you weren't even told in advanced.
But congratulations slash Oh,
you are in that 10 to 15%,
and you can really be destabilized in a
very serious way by such an experience.
Uh,
so I'd encourage you to check out Dan
Harris podcast with me for more than that
or,
uh,
even better perhaps is to listen to my
very in depth conversation with Jack
Kornfield about exactly this.
All right. Two more questions.
Why have you not illustrated
or sketched in your books?
You've mentioned a few times
that you dreamed of being,
becoming a sketch artist.
Why not experiment and your books?
And this is true.
I was actually an illustrator through
much of high school and part of college
for paying my expenses. And
then I just stopped. I mean,
there's also the graphics editor of the
Princeton Tiger magazine at Princeton
when I was there,
uh,
and have designed all of the covers of
my books with the exception of tools of
titans.
Then have had professional illustrators
slash designers come in to do the
production versions.
But I have drawn out all of the covers
of my books starting with four hour work
week. Um, the, uh,
so there's no reason I couldn't do a
62nd sketch each day for say Instagram,
but the books are after the Polish.
I don't want to serve up
my trial runs in a book.
Uh, but many of the illustrations that
you see in say four hour chef were in fact
originally sketched out by me and then,
uh,
the Polish was thrown on for
the production by someone
who actually does that as
a full time job.
But if you guys would like to see me do
a say a 62nd sketch each day, or I dunno,
62nd Sunday or something like that
where I throw up one drawing a week,
that would be a good way for me to get
back into it. So maybe I'll do that.
Let me know what you guys think.
Okay. And the last question,
Tim, I'm a huge fan of how you constantly
experiment and challenge yourself.
So I'm asking you to push me and your
other listeners to do a 30 day challenge.
I am happy to do that.
And in fact,
it's the same challenge that I'm assigning
myself and it's one that I've done
before. This is not a 30 day.
Make it easier. The 21 day,
no complaint experiment.
And you can put this in your calendar.
Certainly there is an
overabundance of negativity,
complaining and criticism on the Internet
and we lose fact of we lose sight of
the fact that it is really a positive
reinforcement and applauding what you
want,
uh,
and not exclusively punishing
or criticizing what you
do not like or want that
elicits change.
You do need certainly at least both and
positive reinforcement and that goes for
yourself and your inner monologue,
your inner voice as well.
So you want to improve your life.
And this is already been tested by tens
of thousands of folks via the blog.
If you want to tip the domino,
uh, like we discussed earlier,
that affects many, many other dominoes,
increases your quality of life,
uh, doing a 21 day, no complaint.
Experiment is a really,
really effective way to go about that.
And it also very quickly illuminates just
how often most of us complain without
any type of outcome or
action coming out of it.
So check it out. If you go to
tim.blog/complaint I created redirect.
So tim.blog forward slash complaint
that will take you to a blog post,
which a you will see is a little dated.
So don't mind the discussion of switching
to the Mac. That was some time ago,
but the headline is real mind
control and then subtitle the 21 day,
no complaint,
experiment and uh,
it takes you right through exactly how
to do it and exactly how I'm going to be
doing it, uh, starting, uh, right
meow. So check it out. Tim. Dot.
Blog slash complaint,
that is the 21 day challenge that
I would recommend to everyone.
And that is it. That is
the last question. Uh,
so with out dragging this out too long,
I would say if you'd like to
ask me questions directly,
if you would like to see what I am finding
most interesting in any given week,
whether that's articles,
gadgets, new apps, uh,
elegant tech fixes. And work arounds
that a lot of my friends share with me.
New Investments. Uh, you name it.
Really anything cool that
I am experimenting with
that I've found that I'm
pondering.
I sent out five short bullets every
Friday in five bullet Friday and you can
sign up for free. It's always
free and it's fun. People love it.
More than a million subscribers,
60 plus percent open rate, uh,
on average.
It's a lot of fun for me to put
together and people seem to be enjoying.
It's chicken up. You can sign
up@tim.blog forward slash Friday.
That's tim.blog forward sash Friday.
And as always,
until next time. Thank you
so, so much for listening.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Fridays.
A very short email where
I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend,
so if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour workweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and you'll
get the very next one and if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it. This episode
is brought to you by legal zoom,
which has been a longtime sponsor because
I've seen it help so many different
businesses.
Hundreds of thousands of businesses of
yours is listeners and even including
some guests on this
show such as wordpress,
the developer and automatic
founder Matt Mullenweg.
Legal Zoom is a reliable resource that
more than 1 million people have used to
successfully launch and run businesses.
Legal Zoom has been helping people
take care of their dreams and
responsibilities. I've got
to protect those dreams,
folks for more than 16 years.
They're not a law firm,
but they have the resources
to keep you on the right path,
including advice from their network
of independent attorneys all at your
fingertips,
whether you want to take your business
to the next level or take control of your
family's future with an estate plan,
for instance.
That's actually one of the places
I started with legal zooms,
looking at wills and so on,
related to estate planning.
Legal Zoom has options so you can take
care of the things that matter most.
Go to legal zoom.com and get special
savings when you entered Tim.
That's capital t I m in
the Promo box at checkout.
Special savings. What does
that mean? I'm not sure.
Mystery savings could be 1000% could be
1% could be 10% could be 27 and a half
percent I don't know.
So go to legal zoom.com and get special
savings when you enter Tim in the pro
box at checkout. That's
legalzoom.com and use Promo Code Tim.
This episode is brought
to you by wordpress.com my
goto platform for blogging
and creating websites.
wordpress.com which I've used for ages
now is the online home for this podcast,
tim.blog/podcast my blog and
all of my standalone book sites.
So whether you're looking to create a
personal blog, a business site or both,
creating your website on wordpress.com
helps others to find you,
remember you and connect with you.
Wordpress is designed for non technical
businesses and bloggers. That's me.
I am not getting nitty gritty in the code.
You do not need experience
setting up a website.
They take care of the technical side
so it's easy to get your site up and
running.
Their customer support team is available
to help 24 hours a day and not just
Monday through Friday but also weekends.
And if you look at the bigger picture,
28% of all websites run on wordpress,
which is mind blowing when you consider
it and plans start at just $4 per month.
Listeners of this podcast can receive
15% off any new planned purchase.
It's a good wordpress.com forward slash
Tim to create your website and find a
plan that's right for you.
If that's wordpress.com forward slash
10 for 15% off a brand new website.